de public sénat bonjour à tous merci de
nous retrouver sur public sénat à suivre
cet après-midi sur notre antenne
l'examen d'une proposition de loi du
groupe rdse
objectif de ce texte renforcer l'éthique
du sport mais aussi les droits des
sportifs parmi les principales
dispositions
ce texte propose de mettre en place une
charte éthique pour les fédérations
sportives pour lutter contre les dérives
du sport business ce texte comporte
également des dispositions en matière de
lutte contre le dopage tout de suite
direction l'hémicycle très bonne séance
à tous l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
visant à renforcer l'éthique du sport et
les droits des sportifs présentés par
monsieur yvon collin et plusieurs de ses
collègues dans la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur le président
yvon collin auteur de la proposition de
loi
non mais on a le temps
monsieur le président madame la ministre
sur le rapporteur mes chers collègues le
sport a aujourd'hui le pouvoir reconnu
de rapprocher les peuples et de
promouvoir une forme de compétition
positive et constructive en tenant à
l'écart les rivalités partisanes ou
violentes outre souvent à la base des
relations humaines
oui le sport peut je dirais même doit
apaiser les moeurs
c'était du reste la volonté autant que
les sports de pierre de coubertin
lorsqu'il a donné un nouveau souffle aux
jeux olympiques et je crois propos de
jeux olympiques qu'il convient de
raviver la flamme originel de maintenir
et d'entretenir cet état d'esprit voire
dans certains cas et pour certaines
disciplines sportives de le restaurer en
tout cas c'est bien dans cette démarche
que s'inscrivent les auteurs de la
proposition de loi que j'ai l'honneur de
vous présenter au nom des membres du
rdse
faut-il rappeler à quel point le sport
constitue un facteur de cohésion sociale
mais aussi un vecteur d'éducation et
d'identité culturelle
je crois que tout ceci n'est plus à
démontrer nous sommes tous très fiers
lorsqu un français mentent sur une des
marches du podium surtout si c'est la
plus haute
nous éprouvons tous une très forte
émotion nous envahir et c'est alors un
grand moment de communion nationale
mais tout ceci n'a d'intérêt que si de
telles victoires sont obtenus à la
régulière dans le respect de l'éthique
et des valeurs sportives
plus largement nous sommes tous très
fiers lorsqu'un athlète et quelle que
soit sa nationalité ses croyances ou sa
couleur de peau accompli une performance
physique et sportive qui repousse encore
un peu plus loin les limites du possible
car le sport qu'ils soient pratiquer
seul ou en équipe demeure avant tout un
défi avec soi même défi physique mais
également des films psychologique
pratiquer un sport c'est apprendre à se
connaître
c'est aussi à mieux connaître et
respecter les autres
au delà de tout esprit de compétition
aura de toutes les médailles que l'on
peut collectionner de tous les trophées
que l'on peut soulever
l'essentiel est bien ailleurs connaissez
la formule l'essentiel est invisible
pour les yeux d'être un homme le plus
accompli possible être bien dans son
corps bien dans sa tête
mens sana in corpore sano disaient les
romains
l'essentiel c'est d'être en harmonie
avec soi même avec ceux qui nous
entourent voilà la première fonction du
sport et de très loin
madame la ministre la plus importante et
c'est bien cette fonction sociale du
sport qu'il faut réhabiliter a fortiori
dans une société en perte de repères et
c'est pourquoi il serait d'avoir de
sport sans éthique c'est notre sport et
éthiques sont comme substantielle et le
rappeler aujourd'hui est bien la preuve
qu'il y a un malaise qui nous est pas
permis de lier mes chers collègues
pratiquer une activité sportive est une
formidable école de respect et de
civisme
le sport est aujourd'hui plus que jamais
au fondement même du vivre ensemble
c'est justement ces fondamentaux que
nous souhaitons restaurer des
fondamentaux que l'on trouve toujours au
sein du sport amateur mais de moins en
moins hélas au plus haut niveau
on a parfois l'impression que l'esprit
de compétition exacerbé par les enjeux
financiers colossaux vient dénaturer
l'essence même du sport
au point que le législateur et les
politiques doivent intervenir et sa
mêlée pour demander comme on le dit dans
un match entamé or provoquer une
réflexion une prise de conscience
collective
je crois comme dans bien des secteurs
qui traverse une crise forte le sport a
besoin aussi d'être régulé et nous
semble que cela s'impose aujourd'hui
pour mettre un terme à certaines dérives
inacceptables car tout simplement
contraire aux valeurs sportives dérive
qui met en péril les fondements même de
notre société et qui joue contre le
sport lui-même
or nous en convenons tous
le sport de compétition et les sportifs
de haut niveau doivent pouvoir
constituer un exemple et un modèle à
suivre pour l'ensemble de la société a
commencé pour notre jeunesse à qui l'on
reproche si souvent manque de rigueur
manque de respect manque de civisme
absence d'efforts aujourd'hui avec
l'hyper médiatisation du sport les
jeunes s'identifient totalement avec des
sportifs professionnels ou de haut
niveau devenus de véritables dieux
moderne comme l'était les héros grecs de
l'antiquité
mes chers collègues nous nous y trompons
pas renforcer l'éthique du sport c'est
aussi penser les maux de notre société
les pensées et c'est en cela du reste
que notre proposition de la poursuit une
cause noble et humaniste
tout comme celles instaurant un service
civique dont nous avions permis
l'adoption par le parlement il ya déjà
un peu plus d'un an et qui donne une
grande satisfaction sur le terrain
madame la ministre
c'est donc dans la même démarche
citoyenne civique et humaniste que les
sénateurs du avait ce s'inscrivent avec
le dépôt est aujourd'hui l'examen de
cette proposition de loi
mes chers collègues il est difficile de
ne pas constater que nous assistons à
une véritable crise des valeurs
sportives
depuis plusieurs années le problème du
dopage en taches sur le monde sportif
mais c'est loin d'être le seul fléau
hélas l'actualité sportive est
régulièrement émaillé d'affaires qui
viennent éclabousser la répète la
réputation de nombreux champions tout en
jetant l'opprobre sur l'ensemble d'une
ici pline opprobre qui se propage du
haut vers le bas du monde professionnel
vers celui des amateurs qui sont alors
victimes des comportement irresponsable
de ceux qui sont censés donner l'exemple
ces affaires qui concernent en premier
lieu le dopage sont particulièrement
choquant est consternante
car ils salissent durablement l'image de
certaines disciplines et il n'y a pas de
place je crois qu'il n'y a pas de place
pour les tricheurs dans le sport où l'on
accepte une compétition armes égales ou
bien l'on est qu'à force
et ce en quoi la victoire ne vaut rien
évidemment il n'y a pas de dopage des
problèmes de violence sur et en dehors
des terrains de sport le trucage de
matches de corruption ou encore de
racisme sont tout aussi choquants et
malheureusement de plus en plus
récurrentes
disons le haut et fort à s'être site
tribune
ils n'ont rien à voir avec le sport ils
n'ont rien à faire dans le monde sportif
ils sont contraires à toutes les valeurs
et tous les sports je ne rentrerai pas
dans le détail des dernières polémiques
notamment celle dite des quotas dans les
centres de formation du football du
football car nous savons tous ceux qui
l'année est d'ailleurs notre texte faut
le dire avait été déposée bien avant que
n'éclate cette polémique navrante et
regrettable polémique d'ailleurs qui
n'aurait jamais dû voir le jour si nous
connaissions un climat s'est apaisé
elle est donc une preuve supplémentaire
de la grave crise que traverse de sport
quoi qu'il en soit l'actualité n'a
jamais été aussi brûlante que ces
dernières semaines et l'inscription à
l'ordre du jour de la haute assemblée
notre proposition de loi issue de longs
travaux internes de réflexion n'en est
donc que plus satisfaisante pour nous
elle est l'occasion pour le parlement
est d'abord le site d'adresser un
message fort sans ambiguïté en direction
du monde sportif
nous avons fait le choix délibéré de
déposer un texte qui prennent en compte
diverses problématiques pour tenter au
mieux et au plus vite de redorer le
blason du sport un restaurant l'éthique
du sport et aussi en renforçant les
droits des sportifs
nous le prenons nous ne prétendons pas à
l'exhaustivité dans les attentes sont
grandes et nous avons conscience de ne
pas tout résoudre avec notre texte
nous faisons preuve d'humilité vous
l'aurez compris nous attendons beaucoup
donc de la procédure parlementaire pour
enrichir et sensiblement nos et
améliorer sans doute nos propositions
mais c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison
que nous avons accepté de collaborer
avec notre commission de la culture et
son l'excellent rapporteur que je tiens
à remercier particulièrement pour le
travail qu'il a accompli
j'ai aussi accepté plusieurs de ses
propositions qui ont dès lors pu être
introduite à notre texte initial lors de
son examen en commission la semaine
dernière en revanche je n'ai pas pu
donner mon accord à quelques unes de ses
propositions qui même si elles sont
intéressantes sont selon moi sans lien
avec les objectifs poursuivis par ce
texte
entendons nous bien mes chers collègues
notre proposition de loi n'a pas
vocation à devenir un texte fourre-tout
portant diverses dispositions sur le
sport et les sportifs
notre objectif n'est pas non plus de
mettre en accusation qui que ce soit
nous proposons plutôt une série de
dispositifs pratiques tendant à vendoire
introduire sur le devant de la scène
sportive l'éthique car il est devenu
intolérable que les messages négatifs de
violence de drogue de non respect des
autres puissent être véhiculées par le
sport
nous proposons donc tout d'abord
d'instaurer des règles de base et de
réaffirmer les valeurs intangibles
auquel le monde sportif dans sa
globalité ne devrait plus déranger cette
moralisation si on peut lire du sport
pas selon nous par la rédaction et
surtout le respect d'une charte éthique
et notre idée est née tout simplement de
la réussite de ce type d'initiative dans
certaines disciplines et je pense par
exemple à la fédération des arts
martiaux précurseur ou encore à celle du
rugby et nous proposons donc tout
simplement de généraliser l'existence de
ces chartes éthiques
les fédérations et les dirigeants
sportifs ont un rôle majeur à jouer dans
le respect d'une éthique sportifs ils
doivent être partie prenante avec et aux
côtés des sportifs
je rappelle que les fédérations
sportives participent à l'exécution
d'une mission de service public on ne le
on ne le dit pas assez
elles devront tout désormais se doter
d'une charte de ce type qui rappellera
une série de valeurs sportives comme la
solidarité la loyauté le respect de soi
et des autres
c'est tout le sens d'ailleurs vous
l'aurez compris de l'article 1er cette
même logique le renforcement des
pouvoirs des fédérations sportives
l'article 3 propose d'élargir leur rôle
en matière d'éducation de mesures pour
réguler leur discipline en effet la
mission de régulation des fédérations et
des ligues nécessite qu'elle édicte des
règles relatives à l'environnement
juridique administratif financier dans
lequel se déroulent les compétitions
sportives
une évolution du code du sport notamment
concernant la définition des compétences
des fédérations et des ligues nous
apparaît indispensable afin de conforter
cette capacité des organisateurs à
définir mais aussi à faire appliquer les
règlements par exemple la disposition
que nous vous proposons d'adopter
permettra notamment de sécuriser
l'institution de la licence club sur le
modèle de celle accordée par l'uefa pour
la participation des clubs de foot aux
compétitions européennes
ce système représente pour lui un phare
un projet clé dans le but de renforcer
la crédibilité du football et cela est
valable
bien sûr pour toutes les autres
disciplines l'objectif vous l'aurez
compris est de s'appuyer sur l'ensemble
de standards de qualité que les clubs de
remplir pour pouvoir participer à des
compétitions et parmi ces principes clés
la transparence ou encore l'intégrité
ainsi une licence accordée sera le gage
d'un certain niveau de qualité synonyme
de garanties juridiques et par là même
des tic
par ailleurs l'article 3 fixe un plafond
salarial imposé en s'imposant au club le
monde du football est principalement
visée car c'est là que se concentre la
plupart des situations les plus extrêmes
on le voit dans les journaux des nez des
contrats fabuleux le monde du football
et principalement donc viser le constat
bien connu tous les meilleurs joueurs
sont concentrés dans une dizaine de
clubs aux moyens financiers colossaux
dont la plupart et c'est d'ailleurs
il faut le souligner le paradoxe sont
terriblement endetté je parle des clubs
bien sûr la bonne gestion financière des
clubs doit être un critère pour le reste
et pour le respect de l'éthique sportive
où est l'éthique quand un club remporte
un championnat ou la coupe d'europe
alors qu'il connaît un niveau
d'endettement record et quand dans le
même temps certains se prive des
meilleurs talents pour ne pas être dans
le rouge c'est effectivement proprement
scandaleux donc déjà pratiqué dans les
principaux sports aux etats-unis le
salary cap puisque c'est de lui dont il
s'agit a pour but de limiter la masse
salariale de chaque club et j'avais eu
d'ailleurs madame la ministre l'occasion
d'en faire la promotion
et d'en demander l'instauration en
france dans un rapport sénatorial que
j'avais remis en 2004 alors intitulé
quels arbitrages pour le football
professionnel
tout le monde se souvient de ce rapport
remarquable sans doute ce salary cap a
déjà été mis en place en france par la
ligue nationale de rugby qui est en jeu
il faut le souligner est toujours en
avance
soulignons le nous souhaitons maintenant
donc sa généralisation
bien entendu il faudra que cette mesure
soit reprise au niveau européen puisque
les compétitions sont aussi européenne
et le marché des transferts et lui
mondiale cette uniformité à l'europe
madame la ministre vous le sait bien est
indispensable une console sur vous pour
continuer à relayer la position de la
france dans sa bataille pour l'un ce
sera difficile nous le savons pour
l'intégrité financière du sport en
europe
nous savons que les instances de l'uefa
présidée par michel platini plaide en
faveur du fair play financier qui a pour
objet justement de freiner l'inflation
des dépenses engagées par les clubs
la tendance est donc favorable à cet
établissement de l'adie financière du
football il faut presser il faut
persévérer sur cette voie c'est la seule
possible selon nous pour restaurer
l'éthique et la confiance dans le monde
du football professionnel du sport
professionnel et général et éviter si
une grave crise toujours dans le même
esprit l'article sein de la proposition
de loi tend à renforcer le contrôle de
gestion applicables aux clubs
professionnels
le dernier article que nous avions
souhaité inscrire dans ce premier
chapitre consacré au respect des valeurs
du sport concerne la prévention
des conflits d'intérêts parce qu'il va
du sport comme dans la chose publique et
que l'on ne peut pas être juge et partie
il est encadré de limiter certains cumul
de fonctions c'est pourquoi l'article 6
prévoit certaines incompatibilités dans
le domaine sportif il sera désormais
interdit à la même personne privée de
détenir le contrôle ou d'être dirigeant
de plus d'une d'une société sportive
dans l'objet social porte sur une même
discipline sportive lors de l'examen
d'une proposition de loi en commission
un certain nombre d'articles ont été
ajoutées avec notre accord je suis
rapporteur au titre premier par le
rapporteur justement il concerne la
revente illicite de billets aux abords
des enceintes sportives ou sur internet
le plafonnement de la rémunération des
sportifs la prévention des conflits
d'intérêt matière de paris ou encore la
création d'un délit pénal de
manipulation de compétitions sportives
autant de mesures qui garantissent une
grande éthique dans le monde du sport
prise au sens le plus large mesure par
conséquent que nous approuvons
pleinement le deuxième panneau ce texte
concerne la formation des sportifs le
sport professionnel est confortée à des
problématiques l'adaptation de
l'enseignement dans le secondaire
notamment de trop nombreuses difficultés
subsistent pour permettre la mise en
oeuvre d'une double projet de vie
sportif et professionnel
la formation des jeunes sportifs est
donc indispensable pour assurer leur
éducation et leur avenir au même titre
que l'engagement de ces jeunes dans une
carrière sportive est indispensable pour
irriguer les disciplines de futurs
talents
c'est pourquoi nous avons souhaité que
les établissements scolaires du second
degré permettent aux sportifs évoluant
dans des centres de formation agréés de
peau s'il y est le déroulement de leurs
études et la poursuite de la carrière
sportive
comme c'est d'ailleurs le cas déjà pour
les sportifs de haut niveau
c'est l'objet des articles 7 et 8 et un
amendement de la commission visant à
ouvrir la possibilité au centre de
formation agréé par le ministère des
sports de bénéficier de la part barème
de la taxe d'apprentissage est venue
compliquer comme l'été avait notre
accord ce dispositif derniers grands
chantiers proposés par notre texte au
nom et non des moindres dans la lutte
contre le dopage
le dopage porte atteinte aux valeurs
éthiques fondamentales du sport non
seulement ils mettent en péril la santé
des athlètes mais il met aussi en péril
la crédibilité et l'intégrité du sport
il est selon nous la négation même de
l'esprit sportif et il constitue un
fléau qu'il convient d'éradiquer le
sportif doit être modèle de dépassement
de soi même au moment de la compétition
mais aussi pendant toute sa période
d'entraînement
la devise des jeux olympiques modernes
situs altius fortius plus vite plus haut
plus fort traduit une conduite à suivre
au quotidien une manière de vivre pour
les sportifs une exigence de chaque
instant autrement dit une éthique
le sportif doit songer à son propre
dépassement avant de chercher à dépasser
les autres
le sport qui à l'origine était une
source de plaisir et trop souvent devenu
sous la pression des impératifs
médiatique publicitaires et financier un
combat acharné où tous les coups sont
permis on voit des voix des machettes de
journaux défaite interdite bon défaite
interdite en sport ch parce que ça veut
dire mais en tout cas ça ouvre la porte
alors celui-ci constitue donc un grave
problème le dopage de santé publique
mission que la négation dons de toutes
les valeurs qui font du sport un
instrument irremplaçable d'intégration
sociale des deux formations à l'esprit
civique et nous savons tous à quel
pression peut être soumises les sportifs
et quel est le poids des intérêts
financiers des rivières ont tout
simplement de l' angoisse de l'échec de
la peur de perdre ce sont toutes ces
pressions conjuguées qui sont à
l'origine du dopage et des drames
humains très grave que nous connaissons
la france il faut le souligner a été un
des premiers pays à réprimer le dopage
en presque 50 ans plusieurs textes
législatifs se sont succédé très tôt dès
1905 65 avec la loi europe puis en 1989
la loi bambuck notre pays a organisé la
répression de l'usagé des stimulants
lors des compétitions sportives
la loi buffet de 1999 ensuite fait de la
lutte contre le dopage
une priorité puis la loi du 5 avril 2006
relative à la lutte contre le dopage de
la protection de la santé des sportifs
instituée agence française de lutte
contre le dopage
doté de pouvoirs étendus en matière de
contrôle d'analysé et de sanctions en
outre l'adoption dans le cadre de
l'unesco de la convention internationale
contre le dopage dans le sport ratifiée
par la france en 2007 a permis de fixer
un cadre juridique contraignant pour
l'application du code mondial antidopage
en fait la loi de juillet 2008 relative
à la lutte contre le trafic des produits
dopants a mis en place une législation
pénale spécifique et renforcer les
pouvoirs de l'agencé française de lutte
contre le dopage des outils juridiques
et des instances existe mais elle ne
suffit pas la france est reconnue sur le
plan international pour son exigence
dans ce domaine
on nous a même parfois reproché d'avoir
une législation trop sévère par rapport
à celle des autres pays elle ne tombons
pas bien sûr dans ce piège nous devons
montrer l'exemple
nous serons jamais coupable de trois en
fer pour le contrôle avait dans la lutte
contre le dopage
la france se sont félicités est
considérablement contribuer à faire
avancer cette cause à l'échelon mondial
la création de l' agence mondiale
antidopage
la marque en 1999 et l'adoption du code
mondial antidopage en 2003 atteste d'une
volonté réelle et général pas rayer ce
fléau
la proposition de loi que nous
soumettons aujourd'hui à l'examen du
sénat permet d'avancer davantage dans la
voie de la lutte contre le dopage la
ratification de l'ordonnancé du 14 avril
2010 était attendu et nous la rendons
effective prévue par la loi hpst cette
ordonnance vise d'une part à harmoniser
les dispositions du code du sport avec
les dispositions les plus récentes du
code mondial antidopage et d'autre part
à clarifier certaines dispositions du
code du sport relatives à la santé des
sportifs et à la lutte contre le dopage
du point de vue pratique il nous avait
semblé plus simple de proposer
l'abrogation de l'ordonnancé pour
introduire les dispositions toujours
pertinentes telles quelles tout en
adaptant c'est l'udc qui avait besoin de
l'être finalement lors de mes échanges
nombreux avec le rapporteur mon point de
vue a évolué et nous avons ré accepter
le procédé autrement la ratification de
londres
c'est dans son ensemble assorti de
quelques modifications ponctuelles
permettra notamment une meilleure
lisibilité de cette loi nous en avons
pris acte
concernant ces adaptations que nous
avons souhaité proposer sur le thème de
la lutte contre le dopage un point me
tient particulièrement à coeur
le renforcement des pouvoirs de l'agencé
française de lutte contre le dopage qui
passe notamment par le transfert du
pouvoir de sanctionner sportifs dopés
des fédérations vers une agence
française de lutte contre le dopage je
sais que cette mesure ne fait pas
l'unanimité et je le regrette fortement
aussi je voudrais bien préciser notre
position ce transfert serait je crois le
meilleur moyen de renforcer l'éthique
puisqu'il permettrait d'ôter toute
suspicion dans les décisions des
fédérations concernant d'éventuelles
sanctions à l'encontre d'un sportif
contrôlé positif car on comprend
aisément qu'une fédération et du mal à
sanctionner l'un des siens quand il
revient à jeter le discrédit sur une
discipline sportive qu'elle est chargée
de promouvoir
elle sera donc toujours tenté me
semble-t-il mais je suis prêt à évoluer
sur ce point toujours tenté d'absoudre
de minimiser ou de passer l'épaule et si
elle le fait de façon totalement méritée
justifier il y aura toujours pas de
doute pour ne pas dire davantage
lequel doute nuira alors aux sportifs en
question comment la fédération elle même
aussi je crois que la moins mauvaise
solution
je serai à mon sens de rendre service
aux fédérations et bien dirty le faire
sur sportive ce pouvoir de sanction
conformément au principe de séparation
des pouvoirs et j'ajoute que la plupart
des fédérations à gré sont des petites
tailles et gérée par des bénévoles et il
aurait parfois difficile de s'occuper
des affaires de dopage
en outre les fédérations pour parfois
été amenés à juger des affaires
similaires de manière très différente ce
qui pose dès lors des vraies questions
d'équité pour les sportifs en fait je le
redis risque de répéter les conflits
d'intérêts me semble pas tant les
fédérations pour mission de défendre
l'image de la discipline et ses intérêts
économiques et la lutte contre le dopage
s'opposent à ces missions
sa phrase non objet d'un débat notre
proposition de loi confie également à la
chance française de lutte contre bages
de nouveaux pouvoirs en matière de
prévention et de recherche nous
réjouissons que la commission soit allé
dans ce sens en rappelant l'importance
du rôle obtenue par le laboratoire
pistache de châtenay malabry en matière
de produits dopants est par ailleurs
dans ce même esprit nous sommes
satisfaits de l'initiative du rapporteur
très actif sur ce dossier dans le monde
vous l'avez noté de données aleph à la
jeune française le pouvoir d'effectuer
des contrôles sur des compétitions
sportives nationales se déroulant à
l'étranger c'est un réel progrès pour
terminer monsieur le président je vais
terminer je souhaite aborder la question
des derniers articles introduits dans
notre texte d'origine par les
amendements adoptés en commission et qui
soit sans aucun lien avec l'objet même
de cette proposition de loi
sans même évoquer le fond de ces
amendements je trouve particulièrement
regrettable qu'ils aient pu être
introduits avant la séance dans notre
texte et sans notre accord à la
différence des amendements du rapporteur
il se trouve pour le moins étrange que
des amendements
le covan a pas aux auteurs de la
proposition de loi puis ceux à la
différence de celui rapporteur être
intégré au texte à la mer la scène
publique
bon j'ai dit et par conséquent le texte
qui nous est proposé aujourd'hui
correspond à ce que souhaitent les
auteurs de la proposition de loi
déception de ces deux dispositions
concernant le contrat malamani sera
l'occasion pour nous d'évoquer ce
dossier
ce contrat de concession entre l'état et
le stade de france d'une part et les
conditions de diffusion audiovisuelle
de brefs extraits des compétitions
sportives notre part c'est pourquoi je
vous présenterai des amendements de
suppression pour ces deux dispositions
qui encore une fois ne rien faire selon
moi dans ce texte
elles sont hors sujet et comme je vous
l'aï dit tout à l'heure il n'est pas
question pour nous de faire de cette
proposition de loi
un véhicule législatif approprié à toute
autre disposition que celle visant à
renforcer l'éthique du sport et les
droits des sportifs
mes chers collègues tout en souhaitant
la suppression du texte de ces deux
dispositions que je viens d'évoquer je
vous invite à adopter
vous l'aurez compris cette proposition
de loi et ainsi de vous associer au
groupe rdse pour adresser un message
fort au monde sportif et à l'ensemble de
la société française
la pratique du sport ou des droits pour
les sportifs comme pour les dirigeants
mais elle implique aussi et surtout des
devoirs et le respect d'un certain
nombre de valeurs et de principes
c'est précisément ce qu'on appelle
tic du sport et qu'il convient de
revaloriser pour le plus grand bien de
tous je vous remercie de votre attention
et je remercie le président de sa grande
indulgence à très généreux le président
merci président colle à la parole et à
jean françois humbert rapporteur de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues peut-être avez-vous
remarqué j'étais un peu isolé au ban de
la commission je voudrais tout d'abord
excusé l'absence de notre président
jacques legendre retenu à cambrai dans
son département par une réunion de la
mission commune sur la rgpp sur le thème
des services publics locaux
cette séance avait été prévu à un autre
moment et ils pouvaient pouvoir être
lançant département aujourd'hui il ne
veut pas être parmi nous je vous demande
de bien vouloir l'excuser
j'ai le plaisir aujourd'hui de vous
présenter cette proposition de loi
déposée par nos collègues du r d eux
veulent attire à l'éthique du sport et
au droit des sports modifié par la
commission dans un esprit consensuel et
avec tout le fair play que l'on
reconnaît à notre haute assemblée on
voit bien ce qui a amené notre collègue
yvon collin et les membres de son groupe
à présenter ce texte
ces dernières années les médias ont
rapporté autant de turpitudes sportive
que d'exploits les violences dans les
stades
le dopage de certains sportifs la
corruption de certains arbitres des
paris illégaux des joueurs qui insultent
leur entraîneur et d'autres qui se
mettent en grève
si tout cela n'est probablement que la
facette médiatique d'un sport français
qui se portent bien
il reste des problèmes sont à régler des
problèmes de comportement et de respect
des règles c'est donc une bonne idée que
d'aller se plate et que d'aller se
placer sur le terrain de l'éthique et du
rappel aux valeurs
d'autant que le sport ne peut être
porteur des valeurs positives qu'on lui
connaît que s'il respecte lui même ses
fondamentaux la solidarité l'esprit
l'équipe le respect des autres
la formule a déjà été cité par yvon
collin mais je comprends pourquoi il a
cité sans nous dire qu'en fait la
construction de cette proposition de loi
repose sur le principe le précepte de
juvénal men sana in corpore sano un
esprit sain dans un corps sain
examinons tout d'abord si vous voulez
bien le volet éthique et esprit sain
tout d'abord le titre 1er de la
proposition de loi vise à inciter les
fédérations sportives bras armé de notre
politique sportive à prendre en compte
des aspects éthiques
selon des modalités prévues par les
articles 1 à 5
il s'agit tout d'abord de conditionner
l'agrément des fédérations à la mise en
place d'une charte éthique et s'écrit en
tenant mieux à son application
la commission a renvoyé un décret
l'application de cet article afin que le
comité national olympique et sportif
puisse se jouer un rôle à la fois moteur
et d'harmonisation en la matière
j'espère que nous pourrons voir fleurir
rapidement lesdites charte après
l'adoption définitive de la loi la
mainmise qui s'est fortement impliqué
sur ce texte nous a même promis
d'inclure des éléments obligatoires
relatifs à la préservation de
l'environnement
la proposition de loi offre ensuite la
possibilité aux fédérations de créer des
licences club
il s'agit en fait de leur confier un
pouvoir réglementaire applicable aux
associations et surtout aux sociétés
sportives qui gèrent les clubs
professionnels
elles seront ainsi susceptible de mettre
en place des quotas de joueurs formés
localement et un plafond de salaire dans
les clubs en suivant le même fil rouge
les tic
la commission s'est appuyée sur le texte
proposé afin de
précisez le pouvoir des directions de
contrôle du contrôle de gestion
celle-ci mèneront leur mission de
contrôle financier de l'équité sportive
dans un cadre juridique solide
j'estime que ces actes de ces que ces
axes de réflexion sont pertinents car la
crédibilité du sport professionnel passe
par sa capacité à démontrer qu'il est
basé sur l'équité entre les participants
aux compétitions et sur l'intégrité des
sportifs et des équipes
bref il s'agit de faire respecter
l'esprit sportif et de montrer que le
sport spectacle n'est pas une activité
économique comme les autres je suis
ravie en outre que la commission est
accepté de me suivre
en introduisant un dispositif
d'incrimination de revente illégale de
billets sportif qui est une source de
nombreux troubles à l'ordre public dans
et aux abords des stades sur la
proposition de notre collègue en bronze
du pont nous avons ensuite mis en place
une batterie de dispositions visant à
préserver l'intégrité des compétitions
sportives face au développement des
paris en ligne
renforcement de la prévention en matière
de conflits d'intérêts et mise en place
d'un délit corruption sportive
tels ont été nos axes de travail la
commission s'est ensuite attaché un
sujet qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur
il s'agit de la formation des sportifs
le texte initial proposait déjà que
l'éducation nationale et les universités
adaptent leurs enseignements pour les
jeunes présents dans les centres de
formation la commission a souhaité
favoriser encore davantage la poursuite
du double projet professionnel et
académique des centres de formation en
leur permettant de collecter la part
barème de la taxe d'apprentissage
voilà rapidement résumée pour les tic
pour l'esprit saint
parlons maintenant du corsa sur la
question de la lutte contre le dopage
qui fait l'objet du titre iii les
auteurs de la proposition de loi ont
adopté un angle original en considérant
que la lutte contre le dopage devaient
également respecter un certain nombre de
principes en prévoyant la mise en place
d'une commission des sanctions et en
supprimant aussi le pouvoir
disciplinaire des fédérations sportives
en matière de dopage
prévoyant la mise en place d'une
commission des sanctions à l' agence
française de lutte contre le dopage afin
de séparer strictement les organes
d'instruction des dossiers et ceux qui
prononce les sanctions
la commission a considéré que ce choix
respectueux des droits de la défense
risquaient de rendre la procédure très
lourde de pénaliser la lutte contre le
dopage en supprimant aussi le pouvoir
disciplinaire des fédérations sportives
en matière de dopage
la commission a là encore estimé que le
risque était d'alourdir le travail de
lagence et que les fédérations considère
qu'il s'agit là d'une défiance vis-à-vis
de leur travail
nous avons préféré leur faire confiance
et la commission a adopté un amendement
sur ce sujet je vous présenterai au
cours de la discussion
la proposition de loi confins confie
enfin des pouvoirs propres à lagence en
matière de prévention et de recherche
comme c'était le cas du cpl des
auparavant ainsi que de nouveaux
pouvoirs en matière de contrôles
réalisés sur les compétitions françaises
se déroulant à l'étranger ainsi si vous
voyez des articles supprimés dans ce
texte
la raison n'est pas un désaccord sur le
fond avec ses auteurs bien au contraire
mais tient un simple ajustement
technique liée à la ratification de
l'ordonnancé du 14 avril
ils disent abandon en conclusion ce qui
n'est pas dans cette proposition de loi
à savoir le volet relatif au
développement du sport qui est à mon
avis inséparable de celui relatif à
l'éthique
il s'agit aussi d'une activité
économique nous devons le prendre en
compte
aussi je suis pleinement favorable à la
fois à l'article 6 sur la limitation de
la multipropriété des clubs et à son
pendant
l'article 7 sur les prêts et
cautionnement entre clubs enfin la
commission a souhaité ouvrir la
possibilité aux clubs professionnels de
choisir le statut qu'ils souhaitent pour
la société sportive mise en place tout
en conservant l'ensemble des dispositifs
contraignants et pertinent du sport au
final la commission vous proposera de
voter le texte qu'elle a adoptée sous
réserve du sort qui sera donnée aux
amendements qu'elle propose aujourd'hui
je vous remercie
merci jean françois humbert et la parole
et à madame chantal jouanno ministre des
sports
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur cher jean-françois humbert
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs qu'il me soit
permis avant toute chose de rendre
hommage au groupe qui est à l'initiative
de ce texte le groupe rdse et qui me
soit permis de rendre hommage aussi au
travail remarquable d'approfondissement
de la proposition de loi qui a été
effectuée par le rapporteur jean
françois humbert c'est un gros travail
que vous avez effectivement effectué je
pense qu'au cours des navettes nous
auront encore l'occasion d'améliorer ce
texte
c'est vrai que françois fortassin
m'avait habitué à ces mots pleins de bon
sens lors des débats sur la loi grenelle
et bien nous nous retrouvons avec le
président du groupe yvon collin très
récents et anciens sportifs de haut
niveau qui connaît bien le sujet et qui
nous invite bien opportunément à
réaffirmer les valeurs du sport
je vous le dis très simplement le
gouvernement considère que cette
proposition de loi est une nécessité et
qu'elle rejoint pleinement pleinement
les objectifs que nous nous sommes fixés
le président la république et le premier
ministre ont en effet voulu qu'il y ait
un ministère plein pour s'occuper de la
question des sports et ça n'est pas
anodin parce que cela signifie que le
sport est aussi un enjeu régaliens cela
signifie que le sport doit aussi
participer à la réponse aux enjeux de
société que ce soient les enjeux de
cohésion les enjeux de santé publique
et bien évidemment les enjeux
d'éducation une éducation par le jeu et
c'est à l'état et donc avec le parlement
qu'il appartient de veiller au respect
de ses valeurs et de l'éthique du sport
nous devons nous devons être
intransigeant sur ce point parce que le
sport ne peut pas être assimilée
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
parfois ni un simple loisir il surtout
et encore moins à une activité de
spectacle le sport n'est pas un objet de
spéculation c'est un formidable outil
d'éducation
c'est un formidable outil d'intégration
parce qu'il ne prend pas simplement à
jouer il apprend à être un beau joueur
c'est moins élaborées de vos formules
mais il apprend à être un beau joueur
car être sportif on oublie trop souvent
c'est apprendre à se comporter aussi
dans la société
alors bien sûr que le sport n'est pas à
l'abri des dérives de notre société il
est comme notre société confrontée aux
violences à l'exclusion aux
discriminations à la drogue aux excès de
l'argent mais sortons nous de l'idée que
seul le sport soit comme la société
condamnée à ces dérives ou alors cessons
de faire de la politique parce que ni la
mutinerie
ni les quotas ni la drogue ni la
spéculation ne sont du sport le sport
doit rester l'un des derniers espaces de
découverte de l'autre un des derniers
espaces dans nos sociétés où nous
apprenons à partager quelles que soient
nos convictions quel que soit notre
niveau social quel que soit notre
origine un dernier espace où on apprend
l'école de la citoyenneté par le jeu et
c'est le premier espace effectivement de
transmission des valeurs c'est la raison
pour laquelle par exemple au sein du
ministère nous avons souhaité que les
clubs soient aujourd'hui soumis à un
principe de six vies conditionnalité je
suis désolé le terme n'est pas très
heureux mais l'idée très simple on ne
peut pas bénéficier de subventions
publiques de financement public de
l'état sans respecter un certain nombre
dax obligatoire dix axes très exactement
tel que la lutte contre le dopage contre
la discrimination ou encore contre la
corruption nous menons exact d'autre
part des actions beaucoup plus ciblées
par exemple des actions de lutte contre
les dérives liées aux supportérisme on a
installé un comité présidé par le député
eric berdoati qui doit proposer une
politique globale dans ce domaine nous
avons installé un comité de lutte contre
les discriminations qui est présidée par
laura flessel et qui doit recouvrir
toutes les discriminations y compris
l'homophobie ou encore le sexisme dont
nous ne parlons pas assez dans le
domaine du sport et bien évidemment nous
allons aussi renforcer nos actions de
prévention du dopage
beaucoup de dispositions ont été prises
dans le domaine de la lutte contre le
dopage contre phénomène de dopage on les
doit d'ailleurs beaucoup à votre
collègue alain dufaut il ya beaucoup
contribué à ce sujet il nous faut
aujourd'hui aller sur le terrain de la
prévention dans le nouveau plan national
2011 2014 nous avons défini trois axes
d'abord le grand public avec des
campagnes de communication que nous
feront conjointement avec le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel mais
également avec la mission
interministérielle de lutte contre la
drogue et la toxicomanie
je tiens beaucoup à ce parallélisme
entre lutte contre le dopage et lutte
contre la drogue
deuxième axe ce sont les fédérations
bien évidemment et dans le cadre de la
civi conditionnalité obliger les
fédérations a adopté un plan de
prévention du dopage et le troisième axe
c'est de s'appuyer sur l'office central
de lutte contre les atteintes à
l'environnement et à la santé publique
le kleist qui s'occupe aussi de
démantèlement des trafics de produits
dopants qui fait un travail remarquable
et qui doit pouvoir demain s'appuyer sur
des cellules à l'échelon régional
alors la proposition de loi que nous
débattons aujourd'hui apporte des
compléments important à cette politique
nous sommes très favorables à
l'obligation pour chaque fédération
d'adopter une charte éthique qui
n'oublie pas messieurs rapporteur les
principes du développement durable
nous sommes très très favorable aux
bases juridiques de la licence club du
fair play financier ou encore des règles
de joueurs formés localement
nous sommes favorables au renforcement
et à plus d'indépendance des organes de
contrôle au sein des fédérations
nous sommes très très favorable à la
diminution du plafond des commissions
des agents sportifs toujours dans cette
principe que le sport n'est pas un objet
de spéculation
nous sommes très très favorable un
meilleur encadrement des paris sportifs
je pense que là nous ne sommes qu'au
début de la lutte contre la corruption
liée aux paris sportifs et nous sommes
aussi favorables bien évidemment à
l'aménagement de la scolarité pour les
jeunes sportifs qui ont une signé une
convention dans un centre de formation
et qui doivent pouvoir bénéficier des
mêmes aménagements de scolarité que les
sportifs de haut niveau donc la liste
d'ailleurs je pourrai pour six parce que
la liste de nos points d'accord et très
très longue
et d'ailleurs nous avons partagé au sein
de la commission présente présidé par
monsieur legendre énormément de
énormément de points alors bien
évidemment il y à quelques points de
désaccord mais ils sont un film d'abord
sur le dopage et j'essaierai de vous
démontrer comme l'a proposé monsieur le
rapporteur que l'article 25 qui n'est
pas nécessaire et qu'il pourrait à
linverse conduire à une
déresponsabilisation des fédérations de
même sur l'article 32 validant le
contrat du consortium du stade de france
je crois et s'est avéré que les risques
d'inconstitutionnalité devrait tous nous
inciter à sa suppression
ainsi sous réserve de quelques
modifications tout à fait minime
le gouvernement soutient très fortement
cette position et le consensus qui je
l'espère pourra s'exprimer au sein de la
haute assemblée sera un argument très
très fort pour la poursuite de ce texte
à l'assemblée nationale et au cours des
différentes navettes qui nous permettra
de l'enrichir par exemple avec les
conclusions de l'assemblée du sport pour
conclure comme les précédents orateurs
je manquerai pas de dire que les valeurs
sont la raison d'être d'une politique
des sports si nous avons eu un ministère
c'est que nous pensons que le sport
contribue à la vie de la cité et
l'éthique et l'éducation vont de pair au
sein du sport c'est pour nos enfants
pour l'image que nous leur donnons de la
société que nous allons leur laisser que
nous devons effectivement constamment
constamment essayé d'adopter d'adapter
pardon la loi et la réglementation à
l'évolution de la société et donc à
l'évolution du sport ce qui contribuera
d'ailleurs à redonner un peu de sens à
cette fameuse notion de missions de
service public comme vous l'avait
rapporté rappelé monsieur le président
que nous confions aux différentes
fédérations
je vous remercie merci madame la mise
alors j'indique au sénat que compte tenu
de l'organisation du débat des cités par
la conférence
le président les temps de parole dont
disposent les groupes pour cette
discussion sont les suivants le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire 19
minutes le groupe socialiste 16
le groupe de l'union centriste 8
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et des sénateurs du parti de gauche 7 le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen 7 et la réunion
administrative des sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe 3 minutes et
dans la discussion générale
la parole est à jean jacques lozach pour
le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mais c'est le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
enfin c'est le mot qui m'est venu à
l'esprit dans ce que j'ai vu qu'elle
être soumis à notre haute assemblée un
texte
abordant de manière large les enjeux du
sport je serai direct je ne crois pas
que la proposition de loi de mes
collègues du groupe rdse révolutionnera
la gouvernance et la pratique du sport
en france mais elle procède hermin de
nécessaires adaptations que nous
attendions depuis longtemps
vous permettrez madame la ministre de
regretter que le ministère des sports
n'est à ce jour toujours pas proposé
depuis 2007 de grands projets de loi sur
le sport comme l'avait pourtant promis
vos prédécesseurs bernard laporte et
rama yade
on a beaucoup colloquer on a commandé
beaucoup de rapports et d'études
on nous a souvent parlé d'avant projet
doit mais la réflexion d'un semble-t-il
pas dépasser ce stade là et nous avons
dû jusqu'ici nous contenter de texte
purement circonstancielles j'y
reviendrai
malgré ces avancées il faudra savoir
aller bien au delà de ce texte
je souhaite qu'à terme ce déposé devant
la représentation nationale un texte
fondateur sur le sport un texte qui
définirait notamment un véritable statut
du sportif de haut niveau
un texte qui surtout resterait une
politique sportive exigeante et qui
serait équilibré les exigences du sport
de haut niveau et les besoins du sport
pour tous en un mot un texte inspirateur
d'une ambition majeure pour le sport
français et générateurs des moyens
indispensables à une telle priorité
tout cela m'apparaît cependant bien
illusoire dans la mesure où le budget du
sport est réduit à portion congrue
car il est certain que les crédits
accordés pour l'année 2011 ne laisse pas
beaucoup de place pour rêver j'en viens
maintenant au contenu du texte qui nous
est proposé d' examiner
il est globalement satisfaisant
l'objectif de l'article 1er est tout à
fait louable et nous ne pouvons qu'y
souscrire les récents événements qui ont
touché la fédération française de
football ont montré à quel point l
éthique sportive pouvait parfois être
mise à mal
je voudrais toutefois souligné deux
points
on a excessivement mis en cause la
gestion du football par le monde amateur
je pense pour ma part que les tristes
événements que je viens de citer de
façon elliptique
on aurait très bien pu se produire dans
le cadre d'une gestion professionnelle
du football français c'est sont accusés
le monde amateur de tous les maux il est
la base notre système sportif
certains appellent à une véritable
gestion managériale du football je le
rappellerai simplement que le monde de
l'entreprise n'est pas toujours en
termes d'éthique et de respect des
autres le meilleur modèle à suivre
loin s'en faut il est toujours possible
de professionnaliser une gouvernance
sans en exclure la représentativité de
sa base fait du bénévolat de ses
militants et de ses acteurs je souhaite
également que la critique ne se porte
pas uniquement sur le football c'est un
sport qui bien sûr a les défauts de ses
qualités
il est immensément populaire partout
dans le monde pratiqué en masse regardez
par des milliards de spectateurs et
téléspectateurs
il est somme toute logique que le monde
de l'argent et du business intéresse
d'abord à lui il est également logique
mais non moins regrettable que ce soit
dans ce sport que l'on observe de la
part des joueurs des dirigeants ou des
supporters des comportements parfois
inacceptables tout simplement l'image de
certains comportements individuels au
sein d'une société souvent en perte de
sens et de repères
le football n'a pas le monopole de ce
type d'agissement les récentes
déclarations de rugbyman international à
propos de l'arbitrage sont venus
rappeler que dans toutes les disciplines
il importe de s'adonner un effort de
prévention et de sensibilisation à cet
égard les dispositions prévues par
l'article à me semble tout à fait
honorable nous souhaitons que soit
confirmé le vote de la commission qui
comme le proposait notre amendement a
établi que la charte éthique élaboré par
chaque fédération sportive délégataire
de service public rappelons le serait
soumise à l'avis du comité national
olympique et sportif français
seul garant de l'unité et de l'autonomie
du mouvement sportif
je regrette en revanche que les
dispositions prévues à l'article 2 est
relative au respect du développement
durable n'est pas été conservés notable
ministre vous vous êtes engagé à
réintégrer dans le texte réglementaire
d'application des chartes éthiques
une référence à ses principes au delà de
l'affichage il faudrait surtout que dans
ce domaine
les décret soit publié et que les
financements sont à la hauteur
on déshabille chaque jour un peu plus le
grenelle de l'environnement et on ne
donne pas aux dispositions existantes
les moyens de produire leurs effets au
risque de me répéter j'insiste rencontre
le carter essentiel du lien qui unit le
monde amateur au monde professionnel le
haut niveau résulte de ces fondations
constitué par les clubs et les trois
millions de bénévoles qui les anime
c'est justement pour cette raison que
dans sa rédaction originel l'article 4
de cette ppl ne nous convenait pas et
nous nous félicitons de sa suppression à
l'issue de la commission
les termes employés semblaient en effet
rendu possible la création de
championnat professionnel fermé sur le
modèle du championnat de basket
américain avec une liste d'équipements
fixes
on serait entré dans un monde différent
celui du sport purement business dans
lequel toute la dimension aléatoire co
substantielle à la compétition sportive
et est dénaturée l'article 5 au
contraire nous semblait tout à chaud
audacieux et innovant dans sa rédaction
originel l'instauration d'un salary cap
c'est à dire la fixation d'un montant
maximum pour la part salaires dont le
budget d'un club professionnel aller
dans le bon sens à notre plus grand
regret l'examen du texte en commission à
édulcorer considérablement la portée de
cette disposition particulièrement
novatrice et facteur de régulation en en
retirant son aspect obligatoires j'ai
tout à fait conscience qu'un tel système
risquerait d'être préjudiciable à
plusieurs niveaux les clubs de football
et cela nous rappelle le débat sur le
dic le droit d'image collectif craignent
la fuite des talents dans les clubs
étrangers
les sports moins aisés rappellent de
leur côté que leurs pratiquants sont
déjà assez faiblement rémunérés oui nous
avons conscience de tout ceci et
j'estime derma qu'il faut s'engager vers
une telle évolution afin d'avoir une
adéquation entre financement du sport et
économie réelle de rugby français a
montré que ce système pouvait
fonctionner aux autres sports de s'en
inspirer à partir de leurs propres
spécificités
les dérives financières du sport le mine
de l'intérieur chaque jour un peu plus
instaurer un salary cap ce serait aller
vers plus de moralité dans le sport
cette mesure contribuera surtout à
assainir les comptes de nombreux clubs
professionnels
qu'ils se sont laissé prendre dans une
dérive salariale inflationnistes sans
fin mais gardons une chose à l'esprit
installe rica pneus sera utile que si
une réflexion est engagée à l'échelle du
continent européen
dans son ensemble le niveau pertinent et
là en raison d'une concurrence fiscale
déloyale les mêmes règles du jeu doivent
s'appliquer à tous il en va de
liquidités de la pratique un article 3
banalisée donc mais un article 6 plus
qui est tiré celui ci traite désormais
notamment la rémunération des agents
sportifs mais également des jeux en
ligne et de la fraude sportive
surprenant nous sommes étonnés car
quelques sénateurs dont j'étais avait
alerté votre prédécesseur madame la
ministre sur les risques des projets de
loi relatifs à l'ouverture du marché des
jeux en ligne et au statut des agents
sportifs nous remarque n'avait pas été
prise en compte
car l'évidence l'important est ailleurs
aller vite pour que tout soit prêt pour
la coupe du monde de football 2010 et
nous voyons aujourd'hui les défenseurs
de ces projets qui vient d'admettre à
demi-mot que oui peut-être ces textes
ont fait entrer le loup dans la bergerie
pourquoi ne pas avoir donné la
possibilité aux fédérations il ya un an
d'abaisser la rémunération des agents
sportifs
en quoi la situation at elle vraiment
changé depuis de la même façon j'observe
que l'on n'aura même pas attendu
l'examen d'une clause de revoyure
envisagé dans la loi pour chercher à
moraliser davantage marché des jeux en
ligne
tout ceci confirme a posteriori les
inquiétudes que nous avions exprimé en
séance l'an passé
ceci confirme également qu'un vouloir
sans cesse légiférer dans l'urgence on
prend le risque de devoir adapter la
politique sportive au jour le jour au
fil des événements et des contraintes
sur la formation des sportifs là encore
ce texte affiche de loi des intentions
mais qui appelle des efforts de la part
du gouvernement
il semble en effet important de proposer
aux jeunes sportifs inscrits dans les
centres de formation des aménagements
horaires semblables à ceux dont
bénéficient les sportifs de haut niveau
mais c'est un véritable statut du
sportif de haut niveau qui convient de
réfléchir
il est urgent notamment d'assurer une
meilleure protection sociale à tous ceux
qui parce que leur talent et leur
travail leur permettent de briller dans
les disciplines sportives n'ont pas
toujours le temps ou la possibilité de
gagner leur vie tout en pratiquant leur
passion au delà je m'étonne aussi que
l'on évoque une territorialisation de la
formation des jeunes sportifs
alors que dans le même temps on a
partiellement démantelé le réseau
régional des creps j'ai eu l'occasion de
montrer dans un récent rapport que la
rgpp avait été appliqué sans grand
discernement à ses centres mais restons
cohérents
on veut consolider le double projet fort
bien nous veillerons simplement à
l'application de cette louable intention
l'état de nos finances et ceux qui les
me répondrez-vous sans doute c'est la
même réponse qui avait été fait à pierre
bordry avant qu'il ne quitte la
présidence l'agent français de lutte
contre le dopage la fld est un organe
puissant essentiel mais qui doit
batailler chaque année pour disposer des
crédits nécessaires à son activité
dans ce contexte il me semble bien
difficile de transférer l'intégralité
des pouvoirs de sanction détenus par les
fédérations à lagence avec quels moyens
la fld assurerait telle cette mission
ce n'est pas faisable mais ce n'est pas
non plus souhaitable les fédérations
estimé cela me semble légitime qu'on les
déresponsabiliser en leur enlevant ce
pouvoir de sanction en matière de dopage
après tout les faits il ya déjà la
possibilité d'intervenir si la sanction
prononcée par une fédération ne lui
convient pas en la matière le droit
existant mais semble donc être plus
pertinent que les propositions de ce
texte
je sais que le point de vue du groupe
socialiste est partagée par beaucoup de
nos collègues et j'espère qu'il sera
entendu
j'en profite également pour saluer la
volonté de prévoir des efforts
supplémentaires matière de lutte contre
le dopage
via les chaînes de télévision publiques
pourquoi en effet ne pas profiter de la
retransmission de compétition pour
rappeler les dangers du dopage et
sensibiliser les sportifs le dopage
touche de plus en plus et amateurs et
ceux ci n'ont pas forcément conscient de
la portée de leurs actes nous sommes là
au coeur d'une problématique de santé
publique
en définitive j'aimerais remercier nos
collègues du groupe rdse pour leur
initiative
alors qu'il est un incontestable
phénomène de société
voir le symbole même de la
mondialisation le sport n'est
malheureusement que peu traitée dans
cette assemblée et leurs textes nous
donne l'occasion d'évoquer des enjeux
essentiels
le groupe socialiste est a priori
favorable à ce texte nous nous réservons
d'un mois le droit d'adapter notre vote
final en fonction de l'évolution du
texte au cours des prochaines heures
je m'inquiète notamment de l'amendement
déposé par monsieur le rapporteur et qui
intégrerait un article additionnel après
l'article 6 il s'agirait là de donner
aux clubs sportifs la possibilité de
choisir leur site
tu société responsabilité limitée
société anonyme aux sociétés par actions
simplifiées
cette évolution ne me semble pas
souhaitable ce serait rompre avec les
principes actuels du sport et aller
encore plus vers une financiarisation
que nous ne souhaitons pas si un vote
favorable intervenez sur cet amendement
nous nous verrions donc dans
l'obligation de nous abstenir sur
l'ensemble du texte
enfin j'espère que cette proposition de
loi sera suivie des amendements des
aménagements pardon qu'elle appelle la
politique sportif français exigent des
idéaux des finalités de grande portée
des efforts supplémentaires effort
financier bien sûr mais pas seulement
je compte sur vous madame la ministre
pour agir de façon à défendre les
valeurs du sport et les intérêts des
sportifs merci jean jacques lozach
la parole est à aymeri de montesquiou
pour le rdse
vous êtes président madame le ministre
mes chers collègues on affirme que le
rugby est un sport de voyous pratiqué
par des gentlemen ne peut y avoir de
meilleure illustration du respect des
règles de la solidarité de la pugnacité
du partage de l'égalité de la fraternité
et du dépassement de soi inhérents aux
sports je ne suis donc pas surpris que
la fédération française de rugby et
d'été la première avec celle des arts
martiaux taux est une pratique quand
fervente à établir une charte de
l'éthique et de la déontologie
notre proposition de loi s'attache avant
tout à la promotion des valeurs du sport
qui s'applique bien sûr aux pratiquants
mais aussi à l'encadrement au cadre
financier et au public
elle répond à un vrai besoin de
régulation et d'émulation sportive et la
commission a utilement compléter ou
amodiés notre texte le développement du
sport professionnel a généré des
déviations contraire à l'esprit sportif
elles sont aux antipodes de cet état
d'esprit que l'on peut assimiler à un
idéal
ces déviations s'illustre par la
recherche du gain par tous les moyens la
tricherie par le dopage ou la corruption
les paris fausser la violence dans les
stades
je soutiens les amendements adoptés par
la commission de la culture sanctionnant
ces types d'infractions les fédérations
bras armé de notre politique sportive
sont l'expression très juste du
rapporteur imbert son récipiendaire
d'une délégation de service public
depuis 1975
elle exerce la vocation pédagogique en
mettant en avant les valeurs sportives
pour tous les sportifs des plus jeunes
aux plus chevronnés
notre proposition de loi impose à chaque
fédération l'élaboration d'une charte et
son respect ainsi que la régulation de
l'activité administrative juridique et
financière
club par une licence club accordée au
club respectueux des règles financières
je me réjouis que la commission veut
conférer une force contraignante aux
chartes éthiques
par un décret cela va au delà de notre
proposition
les ligues professionnelles par
délégation des fédérations sont elles
aussi détentrice d'un pouvoir spécifique
d'encadrement pour que les compétitions
qu'elle organise soit exemplaire
ces chartes éthiques leur seront
applicables
le sport professionnel géré par les
ligues doit tête je le répète
exemplaires et équitable car les enjeux
financiers sont extrêmement importantes
l'introduction d'un plafond des salaires
et de la rémunération des agents sont
des mesures pertinentes pour
désintoxiquer le milieu sportif de ses
excès les retraites des sportifs ont
elles aussi des implications financières
et éthiques
à considérer attentivement les
préconisations du président collen
découle de son rapport sur le football
et mérite d'être suivi ainsi notre
proposition d'intégrer pleinement le
sport dans les politiques éducatives et
sociales pour qu'il soit ouvert à tous
est essentielle
la commission soutient et approfondi
notre texte on renforçant le double
projet académique et sportif des centres
de formation elle doit valoriser ce
projet pour que tous les sportifs et pas
seulement ceux de haut niveau puissent
pratiquer leur sport en accord avec
leurs études par un aménagement horaire
et des facilités d'organisation les
dispositions sur les centres de
formation et les quotas de joueurs
locaux me semble justifiée car je suis
convaincu qu'il faut encourager la
découverte de talents locaux et
optimiser leur potentiel
la lutte contre le dopage dernier volet
et non le moindre de notre proposition
de loi a été le plus discuté la
commission a suivi l'esprit de la
proposition de loi du rdse
car tous ici nous considérons la lutte
contre le dopage inhérentes au respect
l'éthique en effet la compétition et la
comparaison doivent générer non pas
l'envi mais la motivation et la volonté
de gagner de se surpasser et d'atteindre
l'excellence voyais le mans au delà des
règles de jeu de chaque sport plus ou
moins complexes le socle immuable reste
le respect de l'autre et de soi même
une des conséquences de la pratique d'un
sport c'est la prise de conscience de
l'importance de la méritocratie
fondements de la démocratie le dopage
méprise cette méritocratie
c'est un fléau qui va à l'encontre de
l'éthique et qui portent atteinte à la
santé des sportifs depuis le traumatisme
de la découverte d'un dopage banalisée
sur le tour de france en 1998
notre pays est devenu pionner dans la
lutte contre le dopage
le rdr propose drap d'abroger
l'ordonnancé du 24 avril 2010 pour
mettre en conformité la lutte contre le
dopage avec le code du sport et des
règles internationales
la commission propose au contraire de
ratifie l'ordonnancé notre texte
reprenant les dispositions de
l'ordonnancé le choix technique de la
commission aboutira au même résultat
comme l'a souligné le président colin
précédemment la lutte antidopage
constitue une priorité absolue de chaque
fédération qui dépasse l'indépendance
nécessaire notre texte a le mérite de
lancer le débat et de rationaliser un
certain nombre de mesures comme la
suppression des déclarations d'usagé qui
ne font que compliquer les procédures
madame le ministre vous avez accordé un
satisfecit à la répression contre le
dopage et déclaré que votre plan
2011-2014 renforcer le volet prévention
car le dopage touche aussi les amateurs
de plus en plus jeunes et devient un
problème de santé publique
c'est une réalité très préoccupante je
souhaite que nos efforts conjoints
parviennent à éradiquer le dopage grâce
à diffusion pédagogique des valeurs
sportives
dès le plus jeune âge le sport est une
source exceptionnelle d'émotion dans la
défaite ou la victoire
au delà de l'hédonisme il forge avant
tout le surpassement de soi on a pu
qualifier les alpinistes qui sont
exemplaires de ce surpassement de
conquérants de l'inutile
cette conquête pourtant nos construit
elle nous permet d'aller plus loin que
la lutte l'écho la limite physique qu'on
sa tribu c'est à dire de muscler notre
volonté est donc d'augmenter notre
potentiel physique et mentale et par
conséquent de diminuer nos faiblesses
physiques et mentales
je le résume vrai par une fausse boutade
tous ceux qui dans cet hémicycle tous
ceux qui suivent ce débat qui ont
pratiqué ou pratiquer l'activité
sportive
sase qu'il serait pire sans le sport
madame le ministre
faisons en sorte par le sport que les
français est envie de se surpasser et de
gagner pour que la france gagne
merci aymeri de montesquiou
la parole est à jean françois voguet
pour le groupe crc spg supervisant les
ministres mes chers collègues
je vois tout d'abord dire on accord sur
le constat qui vient d'être fait par
notre collègue colin sur les valeurs du
sport et donc dire mon étonnement devant
cette proposition de loi qui par delà
son titre s'apparente plus à un projet
de loi portant diverses dispositions
législatives dans le domaine du sport
dont un certain nombre d'entre elles
d'ailleurs semble être la reprise de
l'avant projet de loi compétitivité
éthique de 2010 que nous avions combattu
avec ma collègue député george buffet et
qui finalement ne vit pas le jour
d'autre part cette proposition de loi
dont nous débattons aujourd'hui ou à son
caractère généraliste renforcée après
son passage en commission sont donc face
un véhicule législatif permettant
l'adoption des diverses mesures qui
n'ont pas grand chose à voir entre elles
me semble-t-il si ce n'est qu'elles
concernent évidemment le sport
aussi il est difficile d'avoir une
appréciation d'ensemble sur certains
points nous sommes encore interrogatif
quand sur d'autres nous restons toujours
en désaccord alors que pour sa part aux
autres nous sommes intéressés même
plutôt favorable si dans la version
initiale de 7 ppm le renforcement de la
place du rôle et la dépendance des
ligues professionnelles nous poser
problème tout seul non les
transformations apportées par notre
commission dans ce domaine cependant le
texte que nous étudions aujourd'hui ne
résout pas toutes les interrogations que
nous avions en particulier à propos de
la suppression du pouvoir de sanction
des fédérations dans les affaires de
dopage nous semble que nous risquons ce
faisant de déresponsabiliser les
fédérations alors que nous devrions
encore plus renforcé leur intervention
dans ce domaine essentiel
difficile de leur demander de faire plus
en matière de prévention et de
dissuasion et de leur retirer tout
pouvoir de sanction d'autant que
l'actualité récente nous a pas donné à
voir des cas de dopage non sanctionné
par elle jusqu'à ce jour aucun
dysfonctionnement de la chaîne d'en
quête de la sanction n'a été constatée
dans le sport français
ou si le transfert du pouvoir de
sanction des fédérations à la ferme des
n'apparaît pas opportun il pourrait même
train interprété comme une mesure de
défiance qui n'a pas lieu d'être
à notre avis cependant si telle mesure
devait voir le jour elle ne pourrait
être décidé que dans le cadre d'un
consensus partagé par l'ensemble du
monde sportif à partir d'une réelle
concertation
aussi au lieu de légiférer saisissons
l'occasion de l'assemblée du sport pour
en débattre avec l'ensemble du mouvement
sportif
toujours dans le domaine de lutte contre
le dopage nous ne pouvons accepter un
débat rapide au détour d'un article pour
ratifier l'ordonnancé du 14 avril 2010
permettant la mise en conformité du code
du sport et les modifications apportées
aux principes du col du code mondial
antidopage
même si nous sommes en accord avec celle
ci en particulier dans le domaine de la
réduction des autorisations
d'utilisation thérapeutique des produits
dopants sur lequel nous avions humide
extrêmement réserve le débat
parlementaire de ratification devrait à
notre sens pouvoir s'épanouir à
l'occasion d'un ordre du jour
particulier celui ci favoriserait alors
l'expression de toutes les sensibilités
sur ces questions l'engagement de chacun
et celui de la représentation nationale
faisant un vrai débat pédagogique
pourrait alors être mené ce qui
favoriserait sa prise en compte dans
l'espace public et son appropriation par
le plus grand nombre
ce choix n'a pas été fait et nous le
regrettons nous allons donc comme je le
disais au début de mon intervention un
texte un peu fourre tout j'en veux pour
preuve tout particulièrement deux
articles nouveaux retenus par notre
commencions commission qui sont des
mesures reprises autre loi mais qui ont
été annulés par le conseil
constitutionnel qui tentent de résoudre
l'annulation par ce même conseil de la
loi de valider fif
la scion pardon du contrat de concession
du stade de france
sommes alors très loin du titre de cette
proposition loi devant renforcer
l'éthique et le droit des sportifs nous
pouvons même parler d'amendements
cavaliers retenus par la commission
ainsi l'article 6 bis nouveau introduit
dans le code du sport ce que le conseil
constitutionnel a rejeté d'un code pénal
ayant combattu contre ce type de mesures
législatives au cours du débat sur
loppsi 2
vous ne serez pas étonné que nous
votions contre à nouveau contre à
l'article 30 de nouveau adopté en
commission concernant la convention du
stade de france est question est déjà
venu il y a à peine un mois en séance à
l'occasion de la loi sur les stades uefa
2016 nous avions été pour le moins
interrogatifs sur un amendement allant
dans le même sens et je continue à
penser qu'il serait temps de profiter de
la décision du conseil constitutionnel
pour mettre à niveau cette convention
nous avons tous les éléments en main
pour parvenir rapidement au montage
d'une nouvelle convention d'exploitation
à ce grand équipement et qu'ils soient
moins onéreuse pour le budget des sports
et s'il fallait gélifiée légiférer pour
valider cette nouvelle convention
un projet de loi aurait l'immense mérite
de nous présenter une étude d'impact
celle ci nous permettrait de disposer
d'éléments d'analysé pour légiférer en
toute conscience des implications de nos
choix d'autres articles nouveaux ont été
introduits par notre commission sur
lesquels nous avons cette fois un regard
attentif
il s'agit en particulier de ceux
concernant les liens entre le sport et
les jeux d'argent nous étions contre la
libération des jeux et nous avons dit
notre compte crâne de voir l'argent des
pronostics utilisé contre le cours
normal des compétitions nous dénoncions
les risques de trafic et de corruption
il semble que notre commission partage
dorénavant donc préoccupations
puisqu'elle a adopté plusieurs heures
pique visant à mieux encadrer les
rapports entre sportifs organisateurs de
compétitions et les emprises des
entreprises de jeux cependant nous
restons persuadés que malheureusement si
les risques seront ainsi écarter
d'autres demeurent ils sont inhérents à
ce type de pratiques
le pari les jeux d'argent la ferris et
l'éthique sportive ne vont quand même
pas très bien en ce sens malgré cet
intérêt pour ces amendements retenus par
notre commission dans ce domaine
tu reste circonspecte quant au contrôle
par les fédérations d interdiction faite
aux acteurs de compétitions sportives en
matière de paris en ligne en vue d'une
éventuelle procédure disciplinaire
ce contrôle et les sanctions attachées
doivent
ce sens reste est entre les mains de
l'arjel d'une part et de la justice
d'autre part en cas de poursuites
comme le note notre rapporteur s'il est
vrai que les fédérations sportives ont
pour mission de prévoir les conditions
de l'interdiction de paris et des
acteurs de la compétition sportive et de
cas échéant de la faire respecter les
sanctions éventuellement prises par les
fédérations pourront dès lors sa pied
sur des décisions rendues publiques par
ces institutions
nul besoin alors que les fédérations
dispose des fichiers clients des
opérateurs pour mener leur propre
enquête
dans ces conditions je ne pourrais
souscrire à l'article 6 5 s nouveau
adopté par notre commission
compte tenu de la réalité de ce texte
faisant de chartes arctique un ensemble
de mesures législatives spécifiques
je ne pourrais évidemment pas donner mon
avis sur l'ensemble des articles qui ne
soit cependant permis avant de conclure
de dire l'intérêt que je porte sur deux
d'entre eux concernant les conditions de
diffusion audio-vidéo audiovisuel des
brefs extraits d'une compétition
sportive et la possibilité de diffuser
des brefs messages de prévention du
dopage à la télévision enfin pour
terminer bien que relativement
satisfaits par certaines dispositions
les interrogations les inquiétudes et
les désaccords que je viens d'exposer ne
permettront pas à mon goût de voter en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie de
votre attention
merci jean françois voguet la parole est
à yves pozzo di borgo pour l'union
centriste
monsieur le président madame à ministre
mes chers collègues il y a un an environ
nous étions plusieurs parlementaires ont
dénoncé le manque d'éthique dans le
sport et notamment la piètre image du
sport qu'avait donné l'équipe de france
de football lors de la coupe du monde en
afrique du sud
je demande sportive s'est
professionnalisé et devient un objet
commercial
il brasse une quantité d'un champ
considérable raison de la médiatisation
croissante des compétitions sportives
mais il est et doit être un modèle vous
l'avez dit madame la ministre pour la
formation et la structuration des jeunes
et pour le consensus social dans notre
pays comme dans d'autres pays
or les enjeux commerciaux et financiers
colossaux du monde sportif prennent le
pas sur l'esprit du sport et d'un
compétition et sur l'éthique le dopage
comme la financiarisation à outrance des
compétitions et des clubs sont la partie
immergée de l'iceberg des conflits
d'intérêts le rôle des agents de joueurs
qu'on situe entre autres une partie
moins visibles mais fortement existantes
qui portent atteinte à l'esprit du sport
porteur de valeurs comme les habits pour
nos jeunes et pour nos sociétés
le sport professionnel n'est pas le seul
concerné par la nécessaire et tiki
douala gouverner le sport amateur voit
aussi l'apparition de pratiques
contraires à l'esprit du sport notamment
le dopage
c'est pourquoi le seul l'initiative
notre collègue yvon collin qui permet
aujourd'hui de nous prononcer sur la
proposition de loi visant à renforcer
l'éthique du sport et les droits des
sportifs jusque là hormis pour les arts
martiaux et le rugby les fédérations à
gré n'était pas soumise au respect des
principes éthiques
pourtant fondamentaux dans le sport ce
choeur sportif n'oublions pas ces
chartes éthiques dans la ligne droite
ligne du rôle éducatif des fédérations
reconnues par tous
c'est pourquoi je salue que la
proposition de loi étant dans l'ensemble
des fédérations le respect de ces
principes
de même ces fédérations doivent pouvoir
édicter les règles administratives
juridiques et financières
qui encadre leur compétition je pense
notamment la règle du fair play
financier exigé par l'uefa pour les
clubs de son ressort
je suis particulièrement sensible à la
limitation de la part des salaires des
joueurs dans les budgets des clubs
professionnels proposés dans le texte
afin que dix courses où le fair play
financier reçoivent une application
concrète et efficace
je pense qu'à défaut de modérer les
salaires des joueurs et de contrôler les
commissions des agents de joueurs dans
le cas d'une conscience concurrence
sévère entre clubs européens sur les
salaires on peut au moins exiger des
clubs que toutes les recettes ne passe
pas dans ces salaires exorbitants il
faut savoir que non seulement les
salaires du joueur ne cesse de croître
mais en plus l'intensification des
compétitions à obliger les clubs à
augmenter leurs effectifs certes de leur
côté les recettes augmenter
considérablement puisque par exemple les
droits de retransmission du championnat
de ligue en france ont été multiplié par
6 198 2005 atteignant 650 millions
d'euros en 2008
l'idée de circonscrire relativement la
part des salaires des joueurs dans le
budget d'un club ne semble pas opportune
je meurs jouer aussi que le titre iii de
la proposition de loi permet d'une part
de faire entrer en application les
dispositions les plus pertinents deux
ordonnances du 14 avril 2010 et intégrer
les dernières évolutions du code mondial
antidopage et d'autre part d'améliorer
le processus de sanction disciplinaire
en matière de dopage qui fait l'objet de
nombreuses contestations
quand on parle des tilles ans le sport
il est indispensable de permettre à
l'agencé française de lutte contre le
dopage d'exercer sa mission en termes de
prévention et de recherche scientifique
d'autant qu'elle dispose d'une véritable
expertise sur la lutte antidopage et
dispose du seul laboratoire accrédité à
matière de dopage
en outre il ne semble opportun de
remettre la recherche dans le giron de
linge ans puisque depuis cinq ans et
malgré le soutien qu'ont
apportez le gouvernement qui avait le
pouvoir de coordonner la recherche s'est
montré plus que timide à la matière à
tel point que les italiens et les
suisses sont en train de reprendre le
leadership à la matière d'ailleurs
madame luminis ce sujet j'avais pas très
bien compris la danse de votre ministère
de monter un comité éthique
cette question devrait prix du vin
compris exclusivement en charge par les
fédérations dans le cadre defferre fixé
par l'état dans cette proposition de loi
en revanche voulu saluer en parenthèse
l'action de supervision de votre
ministère notamment le récent inventaire
des équipements sportifs dans toute la
france ainsi que financement du sport
amateur
ce sont des actions qui permet de
structurer le cadre du développement du
sport en france et le rôle du ministère
dares perspective de bien déterminer le
rôle de chacun des acteurs et tard
agence fédération je me réjouis que la
proposition de loi prévoit une taxe
additionnelle pour financer le
fonctionnement de lagence cela lui
permet de se dégager d'un tutelle
financière de votre ministère mme la
ministre
enfin je me félicite que l'agent se voit
conférer l'intégralité du pouvoir de
sanction des sportifs dopés actuellement
détenu par les fédérations en première
instance
ce système ne pouvait plus durer puisque
la condamnation par une fédération d'un
cas de dopage allait très souvent à
l'encontre de leur mission de promotion
de leur discipline
j'espère pour clore mon propos que notre
assemblée adoptera la légère précisant
que j'ai déposée par amendement avec
également une correction du gouvernement
est relative au pouvoir du csa de fixer
des modalités de diffusion des courts
extraits d'événements sportifs notamment
pour les journaux télévisés
ma collègue catherine morin desailly
avait fait adopter ces dispositions
commission je souhaite juste précisé que
les conditions de diffusion de ces
extraits doivent permettre de trouver un
juste équilibre entre le droit du public
à l'information et le droit
d'exploitation des organisateurs de
manifestations sportives
il est donc normal que les organisateurs
de manifestations ainsi que le comité
national olympique et sportif français
en soient tenus informés pour la mais
chers collègues les raisons pour
lesquelles les sénateurs du groupe union
centriste
soutiendront cette proposition de notre
collègue qui par des mesures concrètes
et en mettant les fédérations et non
l'état au cas ces problématiques tente
de redonner au sport ses lettres de
noblesse aujourd'hui a ajouté que
j'aimerais bien qu'un jour ou l'autre on
aille beaucoup plus loin dans la
régulation et le contrôle des agents de
joueurs parce qu'on sait très bien
notamment dans le football que c'est eux
qui font beaucoup de choses comme
velocity là je crois qu'on ne pourra
avancer que lorsqu'il y aura ce travail
qui sera fait ce qui existe actuellement
n'est pas suffisant voilà je vous
remercie et j'ai terminé et j'ai gagné
humide disent très bien et photos
déborde très très bien alain dufaut pour
le groupe ump
je vois là
si le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues après le travail
d'élagage constructif passez moi
l'expression opérés par notre excellent
rapporteur jean françois humbert le
groupe ump va approuver les objectifs de
la proposition de loi présentée par nos
collègues du groupe eads vise à
renforcer l'éthique du sport et les
droits des sportifs
il est vrai que les valeurs du sport ont
été mises à rude assez rude épreuve dans
ce pays ces derniers temps que la
représentation nationale se devait de
prendre des mesures pour éviter que de
tels événements se reproduisent et je
rejoins la volonté du ministre utilisée
que le sportif doit être avant tout un
bon joueur madame la ministre vous avez
à de nombreuses reprises affirmé votre
attachement aux valeurs du sport
lors de vos voeux aux parlementaires
vous aviez annoncé que l'éthique du
sport serait un des grands repères de
votre politique et pour traduire
concrètement cette ambition vous avez
récemment met en place de comités l'un
sur les supporters et l'autre sur la
lutte contre les discriminations de plus
vous avez lancé l'assemblée du sport ou
des personnalités du monde sportif des
représentants des collectivités
territoriales et des parlementaires
réfléchissent à de nouvelles pistes de
nature à valoriser l'éthique du sport et
pérenniser ses valeurs fondamentales
toutes ces initiatives mes chers
collègues devant dans le bon sens tout
comme à la conditionnalité des aides de
l'état que vous avez récemment imposé
pour inciter les fédérations et les
clubs sportifs à s'engager dans une
démarche de développement durable
je me permets juste regretter en termes
de chronologie que cette proposition de
loi soit examiné avant les conclusions
de l'assemblée du sport premier tour le
29 juin
je pense que certaines des
préconisations de cette instance aurait
pu certainement enrichir cette
proposition de loi c'est dommage ou
peut-être aboutir au texte fondateur qui
veut que tout à l'heure notre collègue
jean jacques lozach
aujourd'hui le texte proposé par nos
collègues du groupe rdse proposons de
nombreuses mesures qui vont dans le sens
d ambition initiale préconisait
même les unissent le groupe ump
souscrites dont je le répète à l'esprit
qui anime cette initiative d'ailleurs
aussi dans notre groupe a toujours
défendues notamment avec pierre martin
et jean françois humbert les principes
fondamentaux du sport le dépassement de
soi l'esprit d'équipé le respect des
arbitres la tolérance mais toutes ces
valeurs qui font le sport dès lors nous
soutenons bien sur l'idée d'imposer à
chaque fédération l'éduction d'une
charte éthique telle que proposée par
nos collègues du groupe rdse
de même nous jugeons pertinents les
dispositifs permettant d'avancer sur les
sujets délicats du fair play financier
du salary cap
ou plutôt du plafond salarial même si
jacques legendre pas là et de la
distance club nous souscrivons également
à l'aménagement de la scolarité pour les
jeunes sportifs accueillis dans les
centres de formation agréé par l'état
nous savons que la pratique intensive
d'un fort en vue d'une carrière
professionnelle est difficilement
conciliable avec une scolarité classique
l'élève ou l'étudiant doit
nécessairement pouvoir bénéficier
d'aménagements d'horaires d'études et
cette proposition de loi permettra à ces
jeunes sportifs de bénéficier des mêmes
aménagements de scolarité que le jeune
sportif de haut niveau c'est le principe
affirmé dans la loi de la suite logique
des classes sport-études l'un des
combats essentiels pourrait affirmer les
valeurs du sport et bien évidemment la
lutte contre le dopage
de nombreux scandales ont écorné l'image
de plusieurs disciplines
c'est toujours l'actualité les récentes
déclarations d'hamilton la semaine
dernière accuse armstrong venu après
laffaire floyd landis forme que notre
tour de france épreuve sportive la plus
populaire et la plus médiatisée n'a à
cause de la perversion du dopage plus
vraiment de vainqueur officiel depuis
plus de dix ans ce fléau mais chers
collègues touchent au fondement même du
sport et remet en cause les tic la plus
élémentaire
c'est un sujet extrêmement délicat sur
lequel
vous le savez je me suis beaucoup penché
beaucoup investi puisque j'ai eu
l'honneur d'être le rapporteur de tous
les textes relatifs à la lutte contre le
dopage
ici au sénat depuis maintenant une
quinzaine d'années et à cet instant mes
propos je tiens à rendre un hommage
mérité un de vos prédécesseurs même la
ministre
il s'agit de jean françois lamour qui a
par sa volonté largement contribué à
faire progresser la lutte contre le
dopage et sans revenir sur les
péripéties de l'élection je ne peux que
regretter pour ma part qu'ils ne se
soient pas présentés au dernier moment
la présidence de la main si convaincu
qu'il aurait fait une excellente
président l'adoption dans le cadre de
l'unesco de la convention internationale
contre le dopage dans le sport qui a été
ratifiée par la france en 2007 permet
enfin de fixer un cadre juridique
contraignant pour l'application du code
mondial antidopage nous nous en
félicitons tous l'efficacité de la lutte
anti dopage parce c'est évident parce
mondialisation c'est-à-dire la
définition d'un corpus de normes
harmonisées au niveau de toute la
planète pour garantir l'équité des
compétitions à préserver la santé des
sportifs
il faut effectivement appliquer les
mêmes règles
en tout point du globe la loi du 5 avril
2006 relatif à la lutte contre le dopage
et à la protection de la santé des
sportifs
ah vous le savez institué la fédé
l'agencé française de lutte contre le
dopage
doté de pouvoirs étendus en matière de
contrôle d' analyse et de sanction bien
évidemment je m'étais félicité à
l'époque de l'equilibre définit par ce
texte
il me paraissait effectivement
susceptibles d'améliorer efficacement la
lutte antidopage sans stigmatiser
davantage un sportif utilisateurs des
produits
en outre nous avons sensiblement modifié
notre droit afin de lutter efficacement
contre ce fléau avec la loi relative à
la lutte contre le trafic des produits
dopants celle du 3 juillet 2008
et comme je l'avais souligné ici
à cette tribune au moment de son examen
une législation pénale spécifique en
matière de dopage était primordiale
cette loi c'est vrai a permis
d'accroître notre efficacité en matière
de lutte contre le dopage à l'occasion
de toutes les compétitions sportives qui
se déroule sur le sol national
vous savez que désormais la garde à vue
peut être prononcée et ça permet de ne
pas cacher les produits dopants ou de
passeurs se dérober dans la pénalisation
de la détention mais aussi de production
du transport de l'importation et de
l'exportation des produits dopants a
donné aux services de police judiciaire
des moyens accrus pour démanteler tous
les trafics
je profite là aussi de l'occasion qui
m'est donnée pour saluer le travail
exemplaire effectué par la fld la fld
révèle de plus en plus de cas de dopage
c'est près de 200 en 2010 et la
représente
et la répression des comportements
fautifs progresse là aussi l'efficacité
de lagence en particulier sous la langue
présidence de pierre bordry elle a fait
un acteur incontournable de la lutte
internationale contre le dopage bien je
rejoins les différents intervenants
il convient de lui donner à cette agence
budgétairement les moyens de son action
pour toujours mieux contrôler et
sanctionner les pratiques dopantes
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance pour
la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très belle soirée à tous